hello everyone I was just browsing the
Internet as I usually do and I came
across a photo of Carlson's sister
Ingrid on Twitter and whenever I see a
photo of her I think to myself so that's
what Magnus would look like with long
hair as they are incredibly similar
which you can see from the photo here so
then I thought I know Carlson has three
sisters but I never knew if any of them
played chess so I checked the database
at chess Gamescom it seems both the
Ingrid and Ellen play chess Ingrid is
rated around 1600 although she doesn't
play anymore since the database only
covers games from 2007 to 2010 so I
don't think she's an active player and
Ellen is the rate at the around 1950 so
since no YouTube channel ever showed a
game by Ingrid Carson died I decided to
show one it was played in 2010 it is the
Gibraltar Open tournament and she has
the white pieces against Nadia 8c from
Switzerland so let's see this game
efore d5 Knight to f3 d6 the Philidor
defense we have d4 and in this position
I'm sure you'll remember Bishop to be
Bishop to g4 is the Opera House move one
of the most criticized moves in chess
history so in the game we have a capture
son d4 which isn't a mistake but this is
generally something you don't want to do
ever because by capturing you la Knight
capture son d5 and you only allow the
whites to improve the position of his
night he was on f3 now he's closer to
the center and it's a it's much much
nicer square for the knight better in
this position then capturing and d4
would be something like nice to d7 or
Knight to f6 and continuing the game you
know it's the best to always follow that
all saying to take is a mistake if you
don't gain anything by capturing don't
capture but okay in the game we have a
capture son d4 not capture son d4 and
Knight to f6 developing a piece for the
temple attacking the e4 pawn Knight to
c3
defending better place
preparing to Castle Bishop to e2 also
preparing to castle
Nadia castles Bishop to e3 now Bishop to
e6 and Ingrid castles Queen to d7 is
played and here Ingrid captures the
Bishop Knight captures on e6 which again
isn't isn't a mistake or anything you
know you grabbed a bishop what a night
now you have the bishop prepare white
still has a very comfortable game but
maybe something other than capturing the
bishop an interesting line would be f4
now threatening of course f5 to trap
this bishop on e6 and after something
like Bishop to g4 push 'if I've and
after Bishop captures Bishop Queen
captures Bishop D captures on e5 f
captures on e5 and Knight to d5 White
has this interesting idea of rook
captures on f7 if you capture the rook
you get e six the knight is protecting
the pawn on e6 and after something like
Knight captures on c3 e captors on f7
would check King captures and B captures
on c3 white would have a very
comfortable game here the queen is
coming to c4 which with great tempo the
rook is coming to f1 this would be this
would be great for white but okay in the
game after Queen d7 Knight captures and
e6 was played and now it does seem more
appropriate to capture with the Queen
you don't want to mess up the defense of
your King but not your place F captures
on e6 and okay you do now get another
central pawn you open up DF file for
your rook but it might have been better
to capture with Queen captures and e6
now in replace f4 we have E 5 and f5
here Knight to c6 Bishop to f3 adding
more protection d4 pawn so nice to d5
can be played so this is like a
preparation move a6 and now G for
preparing G v h6 was played and now
Knight to d5
here you definitely want to capture this
knight on d5 is it's an extremely
powerful piece you don't want to allow a
knife captures on e7 so something like
knife captures on d5 Queen captures on
d5 with check King h7 and it's a much
more comfortable position for white but
but black can hold this
but after Knight to d5 and Nadia decided
to go for for for an ambitious move
Knight to h7 probably preparing
something like Bishop to g5 to exchange
the dark square bishop but of course
this isn't allowed Knight captures on e7
with Czech Queen captures on e7 and c3
controlling that tonight so the night
can't really jump into play kink to h8
probably probably getting the king out
of this diagonal so the Queen can to
jump to d5 with tempo maybe if this
Knight moves the b7 pawn would be
vulnerable and maybe would ideas of rook
to g8 who knows 21 now preparing Queen
to g3 Knight the d8 trying to get the
night to help out with the defense of
the king
h4 now and h4 is the strongest move
recommended by the engine
Knights to f7 but already this Knight to
f7 move is looking for trouble you have
a knight on f7 and you have a night on
h7 this pawn is coming coming to g6
Queen to g3 now preparing g5 King to g8
and this is this is a weird move I don't
really understand this move
maybe making room for the night an
h-shaped but but who knows maybe maybe a
better move here for black wouldn't be
something like rook the g8 to maybe try
and open up the position with the g6 and
capture on f5 but but okay Queen to rook
earth King today it was played and now
King to h1 by Ingrid preparing the work
to come to the G file and here c5 was
played and the C file doesn't really
stop any of White's plans on the King
side a better choice would be something
like
d 5 the white is attacking and King said
you don't want to break open the center
and after something like rook a to d1
and rook a to d8 if he captor son d5
then Knight to d6 preparing the pawn
pawn to e4 move and maybe black would
get some counter play white is better of
course but definitely better than this
c5 move so rook to g1 adding more
pressure to the G file and Queen to f6
now and this is this is of course the
mistake that cost Nadia the game here
probably was was the last tried to go
for something like d5 and after g5h
captures h captures and after Knight to
d6 black would have a very very hard
game after f6 but black is falling apart
here so neither didn't go for this
slightly better defense after rook to g1
she played the Queen to f6 and this
allows the immediate the g5 this now
comes with a temple on the Queen so
after H captures and g5 + H captures on
g5 in this position neither resigned the
game as of course as I mentioned that
night to f7 was looking for trouble
after Queen to e7 g6 would have been
played and one of the Knights is is
going down with check so this never
happened after this HK % g5 neither
resigned the game and Ingrid won this
this nice game in 23 moves so yeah like
I said no channel ever show the game by
a cost and sister so so I decided to
show one and if any of you are
interested like I said an idea of no
Ellen is a higher rated around 1950 so
if any of you feel like investigating
chess games comm if you can find an
interesting game by Ellen feel free to
suggest and I will show that one as well
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it and I am getting fairly close to
fifty fifty thousand subscribers I will
definitely make make
some kind of an interesting stream on
Saturday and maybe I will try to prepare
a chess quiz as a lot of you have been
asking for a chess quiz so I'm planning
a tournament also if I will be able to
prepare a chess quiz in a way for it to
work because last time we did has some
problems because some some people have
faster internet so they get they get the
question sooner than than the other
players I have no idea how this happens
it's just that it just does but it it's
the guy who won the quiz was actually
Tom from Slovenia and he actually won a
lot of chess quizzes so I don't think
the problem was really in his internet
connection he really he said he knew all
the questions except two but you know
there weren't pretty easy questions so
yeah I just wanted you to know that and
I am seriously taking suggestions on
what to do for the giveaway as you know
it would be okay to do a nice giveaway
for the 50,000 subscribers milestone so
if you have any any suggestions feel
free to share in the comment section so
yeah I would like to thank John Carter
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon